ils ont décidé de braver l'interdît
qu'importe les conséquences
sur la place rouge à moscou les forces
de l'ordre quadrillent et embarque un à
un tous ceux qui osent manifester par
leur simple présence leur opposition à
l'opération russe en ukraine
le rendez vous était donné aujourd'hui à
la mi-journée dans une vingtaine de
villes du pays
difficile de dire combien de russes ont
pris le risque de manifester
[Musique]
non à la guerre vous devriez avoir honte
de vous
même quand les policiers l'ont
interpellé cet homme ne fuit pas il
continue de crier ses convictions
plus de 1015 personnes ont été
emprisonnées en russie depuis dix jours
pour avoir protesté contre la décision
de vladimir poutine
d'autres préfèrent partir par peur de
représailles
rohmer départ j'ai entendu
à moscou cette réalisatrice francophone
fait ses derniers adieux
il craint de ne plus jamais revoir sa
grand mère
j'ai vu tout va bien se passer j'y crois
j'espère que je vais bientôt revenir
elle a osé dire qu'elle était contre la
guerre elle sait qu'elle peut être
arrêter à tout instant je n'ai que
quelques heures pour faire ses valises
emporté le maximum d'affaires
j'ai peur de ne plus pouvoir faire mon
job j'ai peur
des réplications de d'avoir dit des nids
des postes sur les réseaux sociaux
contre la guerre c'est pas le sait pas
les russes kaki qui le voulaient ça
c'est sûr c'est pas c'est pas notre
peuple qui est en train de compter
sur la route de l'aéroport ultime
précaution supprimer toutes ces
applications de réseaux sociaux au cas
où elles soient fouillés et interrogés
par les douaniers elle espère arriver en
italie dans les prochaines heures